[Music]
we're gonna go to dave in grand rapids
hey dave welcome to the show
hi hi how are you doing great how can we
help
okay so i guess i'll start out uh maybe
different i have every one of your book
states i've read them all i had your
tapes educated both my children who are
30 and 33
on your
logic of how to
you know stay stay healthy stay safe go
fall into the pitfalls and i've also led
that in my wife and our lifestyle good
well i followed all the steps right i
have a mortgage that we paid off on our
home last year wow
i'm 65 my wife is 62.
she took her first social security check
last week i had her retire after 40
years of work uh she just didn't want to
do it anymore so i said that's it you're
done
so we did that i have about six hundred
thousand in uh 401ks
65 as i said don't plan on retiring
love work
sales engineer for a company just love
work and for health
reasons continue you know
working your mind
life insurance i mean health insurance i
don't fall into that category so i get
health insurance by working but the
question i have today that i don't find
in your book i went to a class on how to
save taxes and money just a class that
was taught at a local school
and the thing he said is your 401k you
should start doing a roth conversion
now
so you're taking the money in my 401k
which are not roth
and transferring that over before you
get to 72 and
that would be a good thing to do
and i'm going to turn it over to you
well um
the tax bracket i mean would be 22
yeah probably and i have room to do that
but the benefit the benefit of it all
being in roth is if you're going to
leave it alone
it's going to continue to grow tax-free
and you can leave it in there growing
tax-free where if you don't you've got
to begin the required minimum
distributions the rmds at 72 and a half
like you like the person told you that
that is correct information so you're
going to have to begin drawing down on
it if it's in a traditional at 72 and a
half whether you want to or not you're
going to pay the taxes on a little
portion every year okay because the irs
wants their money so uh if instead you
have moved it to a roth by then
um all at once or a little bit at a time
over five years or whatever uh you've
already paid all your taxes at that
point
and it will grow tax-free from then on
if you're going to turn right around and
pull it back out
within a few months or a few years then
that doesn't do any good if you're
probably not really touching the money
um
it'll probably make sense to do that
because you probably got another 20
years before the money's ever accessed
really then like to 85
okay
right or 95 or whatever you live to
right right yeah right my dad's 90. yeah
so uh
again the faster you're going to use
that money up
the worse the idea is to move it to a
roth and i think what i'm hearing you
say is you guys are in really good shape
and you probably don't need to access
this money ever
no i had no credit card debt uh you know
paid the cars off uh you're still
working
yeah
yeah
so but basically if we take 600 and we
pay taxes on it it looks a lot like 400.
right
and uh you know and so
but it's going to look like that anyway
when you pull it out out of a
traditional later on so you're going to
get the hit sometime in the next decade
one way or the other yeah so you might
as well put it in there and let it grow
tax-free because i think you're going to
be leaving it alone
it's good because when you start to
transfer it that's you have to have you
have to have the ability to have
the cash though to pay those taxes well
if you got that then that's even better
but in his case he would just use some
of the money to pay the taxes yeah he
would reduce the balance from 600 down
to the you know you're going to give up
200 000 now or give it up later the
downside is is you don't have the 200
000 of going to taxes
growing from now on through it yes
exactly until you have to pull it out
but you got the required minimum
distributions beginning at 72 and a half
used to be 70 and a half now anyway
so i probably i don't think that's a bad
suggestion
it's it's a weird suggestion because you
don't hear that from the financial
community very often why but um
because they've been anti-raw don't do a
roth if you're over 55 because it
doesn't have time to grow okay and so uh
by and large and but i'm 61 i'm not
touching mine i moved everything into
roth years ago and i put everything into
roth now which is the same thing really
like our 401k here at the office i dump
all mine into a roth 401k and i pay the
taxes and move the match over into roth
at the end of every year
so
and do roth personally so um you know
all that so
because i'm never gonna touch that money
yeah that money will be going to the to
the kids i mean it's not gonna uh
because i won't need it i've got other
sources of income